bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france vous trouvez donc
à cette manifestation contre la loi de
sécurité globale le manifestation qui va
être normalement soutenu par le cortège
des gilet jaune qui fête ses deux ans
aujourd'hui beaucoup de dénonciation de
violences policières ont été signalés
pendant lé manifestations du mouvement
quel impact a eu justement cette vague
de contestation sociale sur ce projet de
loi actuel le projet actuel déjà évalué
c'est parce que déjà trois des quatre à
dire qu'on n'aura plus le droit de
filmer les policiers c'est pour protéger
les policiers
il est absolument fonds ppte c'est le
but de diffuser des images dans le but
de nuire aux policiers les vans
heureusement des lois existent déjà sur
le sujet ils sont beaucoup plus frotter
crise et permettre des peines de deux
ans à cinq ans de prison
il en veut que un an de prison quand
quel est le but de cette loi alors qu'en
fait si on veut protéger les policiers
il suffit d'appliquer déjà les lois
existantes donc dire à ce grave problème
voilà donc après sur les images
également c'est que pendant il ya plus
de contrôle citoyen de la police en
france qui creuse le fossé entre la
police et la population
les autres pays européens d inspection
indépendante sur les actions de la
police
chez nous nous avons exigé peut-être est
aux ordres du ministère de l'intérieur
donc si des vidéos ne sont plus
possibles pour contrôler éléments port
de quelques fonctionnaires et cette
vidéo était de fonctionnaires qui va
contrôler la police je reviens juste à
ma première question alexandre langlois
est ce que vous pensez que le mouvement
des gilet jaune finalement et et les les
la répression qui a été policière
dénoncée par ces mêmes gilet jaune
durant leur journée de mobilisation
escale a conduit à à ce projet de loi
vous pensez effectivement c'est ce qu'on
peut penser dont on aurait pensé que nos
dirigeants règle le problème aux
sanctions des paires les policiers
fautifs de ses bottes très graves qui
sont délictuelle et ils ont choisi
plutôt de camoufler la tusiad la bête
sous le tapis en matière de lens il veut
et ça tout est également le deuxième
problème c'est que sans les vidéos nous
n'aurions j'avais su que monsieur b
dallas écrase qui ne sont pas du tout
policier avait commis des exactions
laquelle travaillait pour l'elysée à
partir de demain comment pourrait on
connaître un policier ou un faux
policier devant tous leurs points c'est
qu'ils ont tous le lundi à agadir le
film est loin de prothèses et personne
ne pourra vérifier que les policiers ou
pas donc c'est une loi de communication
très belle piste et qu'il protège les
policiers et les citoyens à part
l'événement
alors il ya eu aussi d'autres bavures
policières présumées ou pas qui ont été
évidemment révélé via des vidéos sur les
réseaux sociaux on peut citer la la
sphère adama traoré par exemple pour ne
citer que celles ci
justement là l'impact d'une telle loi
sur les violences policières qui ne
serait pas de dénoncer du coup à votre
avis ces légendaires donc les policiers
ont déjà fort à faire dans la terre tout
ce temps pour autant s'occuper des
militaires qui ont des interventions
particulières et des textes différents
de la police des fois on profond les
deux corps et ensuite il y aura toujours
des choses qui ne pourront pas sortir
après c'est de savoir dans quel but sont
fait des vidéos six essais pour filmer
et pour pouvoir servir de preuve il a
toute légitimité si c'était pour dieu
aux policiers le mettre en pâture et le
lâcher sur les réseaux sociaux
les lois actuelles permettent de mettre
des peines de prison de deux accords
déjà et la nouvelle loi en fait je perds
être en prison donc si c'est réellement
pour protéger les policiers du lynchage
sur les réseaux sociaux est complètement
nulle peuple loin et c'est pour essayer
d'intimider les gens pour pas qu'on soit
filmé et là c'est bien mais est-ce que
tu te démocratie alors justement ce
projet de loi sur la sécurité globale
prévoit aussi d'encadrer l'aisne la
diffusion d'image monde et policiers
mais aussi des gendarmes
oui attendait tous avaient toute
réflexion était de fait que je ne
connais pas le cadre d'intervention des
gendarmes ils sont militaires et qui
n'ont pas les bep cap d'intervention que
les policiers donc dans la sphère à
tabac est trop riche de maîtrise pas
tous les tenants et aboutissants des
doctrines de la gendarmerie cité de ce
côté là sinon effectivement les deux
sont soumis au même réseau règles pour
être filmés aujourd'hui je le disais
donc le mouvement des gilets jaunes
à deux ans donc cette mobilisation cet
après midi du côté de montparnasse
et justement est-ce que qu'est ce qui a
changé à votre avis au niveau de ce
mouvement il ya eu c'est vrai cette
épidémie à la crise économique aussi
est ce que les revendications des gilets
jaunes ont évolué vous pensez les
revendications ses doigts les saisir des
modifications déchets les autres depuis
le début c'est de bien vivre et avoir un
meilleur pouvoir d'achat et pouvoir
vaquer librement à ses affaires avoir du
temps de détente et pas qu'eux étaient
des bourreaux de travail
donc le mieux vivre je pense que tu es
toujours d actualité malheureusement
après faut réfléchir aux méthodes pour
aboutir certaines méthodes parlons pas
aboutir aux résultats espérés
donc il faut se renouveler tout en
respectant les cadres légaux il vous
pensez que justement vous qui avez suivi
de très près ce mouvement il va se
renouveler un souhaitable parce qu'il ya
toujours une demande de la population
française d'un vieux vives de pouvoir
sortir et se confirmant le vôtre bien
c'est que c'est très mal vécu de pouvoir
de les priver d'aller dans les lieux de
loisirs les dieux des temps de voir des
amis il ya toutes ces combines était
française qu'encore plus mis à mal
qu'avant donc effectivement ça va
rebondir maintenant il faut savoir faire
la part des choses
avec la crise sanitaire qui est là
évidemment et avec qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire ou pas mais il ya quelque chose de
fondamental en france on veut vivre
heureux on veut vivre joyeuse et du coup
pour le vent s'est tassée borroso
qu'effectivement a priori la
contestation sociale les pouvoirs divers
et variés vont se renouveler et après
estero que ça puisse aboutir dès façon
pacifique
dernière question qui concerne aller les
enquêtes sur les violences policières
confiée à l'igpn
c'est vrai que les gilets jaunes ont été
très concernés
ces enquêtes elles ont bondi de 40% en
2019 plus d'un tiers concernent des
interventions donc lors de
manifestations le traitement judiciaire
ce qui l'a ensuite j'ai fait déjà
présenté les conclusions de son choix à
l'autorité judiciaire
dire qu'en fait l'analyse abords du
ministère de l'intérieur du directeur
général de la police et tous ces
fonctionnaires sont aux ordres des rares
chic de leurs supérieurs donc c'est à
dire que déjà même si le procureur ou le
juge qui est lobé sur le dossier il
devra se baser sur les conclusions de
l'igpn complète faussé dès le départ on
a pu le voir par exemple sur la terre
steve à nantes
kan s'est dit jpmc directeur de l'anc
est donc une enquête administrative
circulez ya rien à voir donc si valence
c'était quelqu'un qui faisait la fête
avait pas de contexte à 17,2
manifestation qui s'est noyé dans la
loire à cause d'une charge de police
l'écossé confié l enquête de police
judiciaire sous la tutelle d'un
magistrat directement on arrive aux
mêmes conclusions
il ya des fautes de la police donc on
voit bien que les gp dans sa pose un
problème et c'est une exception dans les
démocraties européennes
donc en fait c'est plutôt de ce côté là
qu'il faut voir avant que la justice
suivre c'est des méthodes d'enquêté
quels sont les pressions hiérarchiques
qui peuvent être données sur vos
collègues merci beaucoup à vous à
alexandre langlois je rappelle que vous
êtes policier secrétaire général du
syndicat vie j ai donc vous êtes sur
place là où doit se dérouler à 16 heures
donc ce rassemblement cette
manifestation contre le projet de loi de
sécurité global examiné au sein de
l'hémicycle où aujourd'hui chien